bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
ce matin des auditions sur le projet de
loi de réforme pénale dont l'examen est
prévu devant le Parlement en juin alors
ce texte prévoit la suppression des
peines planchées et la création d'une
peine de probation exécuté en milieu
ouvert ces mesures doivent permettre de
limiter la surpopul carcérale et de
lutter contre la récidive avec
68850 personnes incarcérées le nombre de
détenus a atteint un nouveau record au
1er avril c'est une augmentation de 38 %
en 10 ans ce que rappelle Robert Banin
dans l'audition que vous allez pouvoir
entendre l'ancien garde des sauts qui a
par ailleurs plaidé contre les peines
planchées qui renforce selon lui la
surpopulation carcérale je vous propose
donc d'écouter Jean-Marie de la rue le
contrôleur général des lieu de privation
de liberté puis Robert Badinter ancien
sénateur et ancien garde des saut je
voudrais dire que naturellement mon
rôle dans ce à l'égard de ce projet de
loi est limité puisque il porte
essentiellement sur des choses qui vont
se passer hors des lieux d'enfermement
et je suis naturellement radicalement
incompétent sur le milieu ouvert en
revanche je voudrais m'interroger sur
les liens que peuvent avoir ces
dispositions qui vous sont présentées
avec le milieu fermé et à cet égard je
voudrais partir d'un postulat très
simple il y a un lien entre les
conditions détenstion et la
récidive et ce lien se décline en
quelque sorte en deux
acxiome le premier c'est que je crois
qu'une bonne prise en charge au sein de
la prison facilite l'insertion et par
conséquent
écarte les personnes condamnées de la
récidive et
corolairement
je crois que de mauvaises conditions
d'existence en détenenstion celles qui
méconnaissent la dignité des personnes
facilit la
récidive ceci est un
postulat rien ne vient le démontrer
aisément sauf certaines études
d'anglo-saxon qui l'ont à peu près
montré mais en tout cas en France rien
ne peut le dire mais c'est ma conviction
profonde et c'est celle qui repose en
tout cas sur
euh c'est celle qui est l'inspiration
des textes qui sont à la source du
contrôle général
et voilà pourquoi sans doute je suis ici
présent j'avais en effet indiqué devant
la conférence du consensus qui a précédé
ce projet de loi en février 2013 que si
aucune disposition de ce projet
n'aboutissait à modifier la vie en
prison ce projet raterait en partie son
but en d'autres
termes ce dont les détenus se
plaignent ce n'est pas sauf exception du
principe de leur peine et même en
général de son quantum sauf les longues
peines mais de leurs conditions
d'existence et de l'irréalité des aides
qui leur sont proposé à la
sortie et c'est au regard de ces
propositions de départ que je voudrais
développer trois points très rapidement
quelques éléments généraux de contexte
d'autre part commenter ce qui se trouve
dans ce projet et commenter enfin ce qui
ne s'y trouve
pas le contexte je voudrais dire ceci
d'abord que la politique pénale consiste
évidemment à définir premièrement des
incriminations deuxièmement les
sanctions qui leur sont applicables et
les procédures par lesquelles ces
sanctions vont être prises et enfin les
modalités d'exécution de ces sanctions
je voudrais rappeler aussi que la loi
serait partie très inégalement entre ces
trois secteurs si je puis dire elle elle
est surabondante mais à bon droit
naturellement en vertu de la
Constitution sur les deux premiers
objets les incriminations et ce qui
concerne la sanction et ces procédures
elle est très peu diserte sur les
modalités d'exécution de ces
sanctions quand on regarde les volumes
du du code de procédure pénale quand on
regarde il y a 100 spécialistes de
procédure pénale dans ce pays il y en a
TR ou qu sur l'exécution de la
peine et naturellement les choses sont
en train d'évoluer je veux saluer ici
l'effort qu'a fait cette assemblée en
matière dans moment de la loi
pénitentiaire je voudrais appeler aussi
l'attention de cette assemblée sur
l'intérêt de la question priorité de
constitutionnalité à laquelle le Conseil
constitutionnel a répondu pas plus tard
que vendredi dernier 25 avril dans
lequel il a expliqué que s'agissant de
la mise en œuvre des droits fondamentaux
des personnes privées liberté il
revenait au législateur de les
préciser mais reste que la loi est
encore peu bavarde sur les modalités
d'exécution des
peines je voudrais rappeler aussi que
nous sommes je n'apprends rien personne
pardonnezle moi dans un état de
surpopulation carcérale je voudrais dire
que cette surpopulation récente
euh quatre chiffres en 1975 il y a 28000
personnes écrouées au 1er janvier en
1985 10 ans plus tard 45000 en
1995 10 ans plus tard 53000
en 2005 59000 et aujourd'hui
68600 les taux d'accroissement dans ces
décennies de la population carcérale
dont je viens de parler de 75 à 85 c'est
60 % puisqu'on parlait on partait
évidemment quantité relativement modeste
de 85 à 95 c'est 17 et plus pour de 95 à
2005 11% de 2005 à aujourd'hui 16 % est
d'avantage ce que ce que je veux dire
aussi c'est que le taux d'incarcération
c'est-à-dire le rapport entre la
population et le nombre de détenus
plutôt l'inverse le nombre de détenus et
la population d'ensemble sur le très
long terme c'est-à-dire au fil des 19e
20e siècles n'a cessé de
baisser et depuis une quinzaine d'années
ce taux remonte et nous sommes revenus
aujourd'hui à un taux d'incarcération
qui était celui de la fin du 19e
siècle le taux d'incarcération n'a pas
cessé de baisser sauf à la Libération
exception très notable mais ça a été un
bref instant et tout le monde en
comprend les raisons mais nous sommes là
depuis une quinzaine d'années revenus en
arrière ce rythme rapide ne s'explique
évidemment pas par les seuls effets de
la délinquence et je dis souvent
pardonnez-moi de me répéter devant vous
que cette évolution est le fruit de
facteurs multiples et c'est en agissant
sur ces facteurs multiples qu'on
interviendra sur ce domaine et ces
facteurs ce sont évidemment les auteurs
d'infraction même ce sont évidemment
c'est évidemment la loi ce sont les
juges qui appliquent la loi mais c'est
aussi de manière indirect ceux qui sont
chargés d'ex d'exécuter les peines voyez
mon postulat initial et c'est aussi
l'environnement de l'auteur et notamment
ces liens familiaux le meilleur
instrument de prévention de la récidive
que je connaisse c'est la famille ou
pour dire les choses plaisamment à la
matière d'un journaliste américain c'est
le 30e anniversaire c'est-à-dire qu'à ce
moment-là on se calme un petit peu il
ont quand même moins d'infraction à cet
âge-là bon c'est dire que nos
instruments à nous les instruments
étatiques ne remplissent pas tout à fait
le rôle ou en tout cas n'occupent pas
une place centrale
dans le fait qu'une personne va quitter
la
délinquence par conséquent si on veut
prévenir la récidive je crois qu'il faut
agir sur tous ces facteurs et pas
seulement le
système le dispositif mais mise en place
par
l'État je voudrais aussi insister sur ce
que j' disais d'entrée sur les
conditions d'existence de la prison je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de prison sans
respect de la dignité j'ai conscience
que en employant ce terme j'emploie un
terme extrêmement galvaudé d'usage
abusif intempestif je voudrais préciser
expérience faite si on peut me permettre
ceci c'est-à-dire au bout de 6 ans
d'investigation dans les établissements
pénitentiaires ce que c'est pour moi que
dignité elle se décline en trois trois
volets très très très clairement
individualisés le premier c'est le
respect de l'intégrité physique le
second c'est l'assurance de conditions
matérielles qui sont en rapport avec les
exigences de la personne et troisième
élément c'est la faculté de conserver
des relations
sociales si ces trois élémentsl ne sont
pas réunis j'estime que la dignité n'est
pas respectée et elle ne l'est pas bien
souvent alors je voudrais en venir
maintenant après ces quelques préalables
très généraux qu'on me pardonnera
peut-être à ce que dit la loi
elle-même et je voudrais ici avant de
venir à à certaines dispositions je vais
pas les commenter toutes pour la raison
que j'ai dit j'ai dit aussi d'emblé je
vais
d'abord essayer de de revenir sur au
fond quelques principes de cette loi je
voudrais en en dire
trois les deux premiers me paraissent
positif le troisème paraissant soulever
quelques
interrogations le le premier principe
qui me réjouit c'est l'introduction
claire dans la loi de la notion de peine
restrictive de
liberté c'est un une apparition qui
passe un peu inaperçue mais que je
voudrais saluer sur laquelle je voudrais
insister euh à côté du traditionnel
évidemment peine privative de liberté
peine restrictive de
liberté je crois que c'est une notion
très intéressante et par là cette notion
nous introduit à l'idée que la sanction
pénale et par conséquent la sévérité ne
sont pas nécessairement liés à la
prison c'est une idée
importante c'est pas une nouveauté
absolue naturellement dans notre droit
pénal
c'est pour prendre qu'un exemple travail
d'intérêt général et bien restrictif de
liberté ça n'est pas une peine privative
de liberté c'est bien une sanction
pénale mais c'est la première fois à ma
connaissance que la loi distingue
clairement cette notion on pourrait
d'ailleurs demander se demander si
l'expression est bien exacte en réalité
je crois qu'il s'agit plutôt d'une peine
restrictive de droit que de peine
restrictive de liberté mais peu importe
je ne boute pas mon plaisir et je trouve
que c'est une notion intéressante le
deuxième principe que je voudrais saluer
qui se trouve plutôt à la fin du projet
c'est le principe de ce que la loi
appelle le projet appelle le retour à la
liberté
contrôlé suivi et progressif il s'agit
du retour qui est contrôlé suivi et
progressif retour à la liberté contrôlé
suivi et progressif ça c'est assez près
de ma sphère de compétence c'est une
question évidemment intéressante depuis
longtemps je dis que la vérité de la
prison la vérité du système pénitentire
c'est-à-dire de son efficacité réside
moins dans le jour d'entrée euh du puni
en prison que dans le jour de sa sortie
et bien l'idée de ce
retour progressif à la liberté
m'intéresse parce que il y a des gens
qui sont plus ou moins bien préparés il
y a des gens qui sont plus ou moins
aidés chacun sait aujourd'hui la
ministre l' indiqué abondamment que il
existe encore 80 % de sortie sèche et
par conséquent l'idée d'un retour à la
liberté suivi et même progressif me
paraît tout à fait intéressant encore
une fois ça n'est pas tout à fait
nouveau la semiberté correspond
exactement à cette affaire la liberté
conditionnelle aussi mais il me paraît
là y avoir là aussi l'introduction d'un
principe tout à fait intéressant on
pourrait d'ailleurs imaginer des
variations beaucoup plus fortes que Cell
qui qui existent aujourd'hui dans le
code de procéure pénale sur ce
thèmeel il y a quelques hésitations
qu'on peut avoir dans la déclinaison que
fait la loi de ce principe euh moi je
regrette que euh ce retour progressif à
l'activité ce qu' se cantonne au fond à
des formes déjà existantes dans le code
au procéus qu'elles sont euh pour les
plus les condamnés à une peine de plus
de 5 ans la seule liberté conditionnelle
et pour les moins de 5 ans si je puis
dire euh la liberté conditionnelle la
SEM liberté et cetera et cetera je crois
qu'on aurait peut-être pu imaginer
d'autres
formule deuxièmement euh je ne comprends
pas bien pourquoi s'agissant des plus
plus de 5
ans la loi dit que l'accès à la liberté
conditionnelle est subordonné à l'accord
de la personne détenue à l'octroit de
cette liberté conditionnelle je trouve
ça étrange s'agissant d'une sanction
pénale car c'est bien la forme de la
sanction pénale qu'elle prend qu'elle
soit subordonnée à l'accord de la
personne détenue je ne crois pas qu'on
est jusqu'à présent de précédent dans le
code de procédure pénale qui indique ou
plutôt dans le code pénal qui indique
que la sanction pénale est subordonnée à
l'accord d'intéressé sauf très cas très
exceptionnel du type précisé travail
d'intérêt général ou mais cette
disposition me surprend un petit
peu je crois aussi que euh je suis
interrogatif sur la temporalité de de ce
retour
progressif on dit euh comme vous l'avez
bien saisi qu'au bout de 2 ti3
d'exécution de la peine il y a un
rendez-vous obligatoire avec le et
que la forme que doit prendre un
éventuel
élargissement c'est-à-dire semiberté et
cetera et cetera euh peut durer ou doit
durer le temps qui reste à courir de
l'exécution de la peine parmi ces
possibilités il y a notamment la
semiberté et le bracelet électronique
comme on dit c'est-à-dire le placement
sous surveillance électronique j'attire
votre attention sur le fait
que tant en matière de semi liberté
qu'en matière de bracelet électronique
ce sont là des régimes extrêmement
contraignants qui sont assez mal
supportés au bout de quelques mois et
pour tout dire on estime raisonnable que
ces formes de sanction pénal ne doivent
pas excéder 6 mois dans la plupart des
cas si vous avez une peine de 3 ans
rendez-vous par conséquent au bout de 2
ans le élargi ça veut dire que vous
aurez un bracelet électronique pendant
une année entière je m'interroge sur
cette durée sous ces réserves
euh je trouve que l'idée même le
principe que j'évoqué est intéressant le
troisième principe que je voudrais
évoquer c'est le sens que peut avoir
dans le contexte qui est donné par le
projet de loi désormais la sanction de
l'emprisonnement au fond ce que je note
avec évidemment intérêt sans être
capable d'en juger tous les aspects
l'apparition de la contrainte
pénale ce que je regrette beaucoup c'est
que on n'est pas dit clairement la place
que cette contrainte tenait par rapport
aux autres sanctions
pénales il y a deux options possibles en
réalité la première c'est de dire au
fond quelle que soit la gravité de
l'infraction si l'auteur et au fond ou
la personnalité de l'auteur est adaptée
à la contrainte pénale alors il faut lui
donner cette contrainte c'est ce que
semble indiquer la loi lorsqu'elle dit
dans le cas où la personne requiert un
suivi socio-éducatif particulièrement
dévelppé ce sont pas ces termes exacts
mais ce sont presque ces termes donc
elle semble pencher sur cette
hypothèse mais il y a une deuxième
hypothèse qui est de
dire la contrainte pénale c'est une
sanction moins grave que la prison
autrement dit elle vient s'intercaler
dans une sorte d'échelle progressive de
sanction pénale entre les alternatives à
l'incarcération et l'incarcération
elle-même et c'est ce que semble dire la
loi par ailleurs elle-même qui dit on ne
peut punir d'une contrainte pénale que
les personnes qui encourt un délibre
pour lequel la sanction encouru et 5
Anson donc la loi hésite elle-même si je
puis dire entre ces deux hypothèses je
pense en réalité qu'elle est orientée
vers la deuxème vers la seconde
directctement et je pense par conséquent
que dans l'esprit des auteurs de la loi
mais encore une fois je rien ne vient à
laappu sauf le texte de la loi lui-même
et je crois qu'il y a encore beaucoup
trop d'ambigué sur ce
point la contrainte pénale devient en
quelque sorte une dernière sanction
avant la
prison si j'insiste sur ce point c'est
qu'on a un peu la même chose s'agissant
des
mineurs la sanction du centre éducatif
fermé comporte exactement les mêmes
ambiguïés pour certains magistrats
elle est antichambre de la prison donc
la peine la plus grave avant la prison
mais pour d'autres c'est une sorte
d'avertissement solennel qu'on peut
donner à des adolescents qui sont
adaptés pour cela et qui sont stibles
d'entendre et dans l'esprit de ces
magistrats là il n'y aura pas de prison
s'il bon voilà et je voudrais cette
ambiguïté génératrice un peu de désordre
dans la population des CEF et je
voudrais bien mettre en garde sur
ce qu'il advient si la deuxème hypothèse
prévaut c'est-à-dire l'idée que la
contrainte pénale est en quelque sorte
pardon de schématiser ma pensée mais
l'antichambre de la prison pourquoi
parce qu'on va transformer la prison en
un lieu de rebut définitif qui va
corrompre très profondément les
conditions d'existence
carcérale au fond pour prendre une image
vous savez c'est comme dans l'ancien
temps il y avait une multitude de
collèges il y avait le collège brillant
il y avait les cet et cetera et suivant
l'affectation des élèves et ben ils se
comportaient plus ou moins bien parce
qu'ils savaient qu'ils était relégué au
dernier rang de la classe si je puux
dire je parle des CET bon je crains que
si ça n'est pas la première hypothèse
qui prévaut c'est-à-dire celle d'une
peine adaptée à la
personnalité mais celle d'une peine qui
se décide en fonction des effets plus ou
moins graves qu'elle recè on aura une
transformation des conditions carcérales
je voudrais insister sur ce point et je
trouve que la loi mérite des
éclaircissements sur ce point je ne fais
pas grillef à la garde des sauts de ne
pas l'avoir fait mais je crois qu'il
serait nécessaire de lui demander des
explications avant avant que cette loi
ne soit voté peut-être que le
législateur lui-même pourra trouver à
éclaircir ce pointl j'enviens à quelques
dispositions plus
particulières je n'insiste pas sur la
disparition
des peines minimales en cas de récidif
qui ont été institué par la loi du 10
aoû
2007 je rappelle que cette loi a eu des
effets moins que prévu toutefois puisque
selon une étude qui est parue en
2012 les peines minimum ont été appliqué
dans 38 % des cas éligibles autrement
dit dans les autres cas le juge a opposé
la motivation particulière ce qui est
bien d'ailleurs la preuve que la loi
pénale dépend strictement de de
l'application qu'en font les juges donc
la portée de cette loi n'a pas eu tous
les effets qu'on prévoyait au départ il
est néanmoins incontestable que d'une
part elle a rempli quand même un peu
pour sa part les prisons et que d'autre
part elle elle pouvait en effet
apparaître comme poser problème au
regard du principe de naadation même si
je n'ignore pas que le 9 août 2007 le
Conseil constitionnel avait donné son
accord à cette loi
euh deuxièmement me paraît intéressant
tout de même et bien peu souligné
d'ailleurs dans ce qu'on a dit de la loi
l'absence de révocation automatique du
surs simple je crois que c'est une
faculté en effet qui vient d'ailleurs
d'un d'un rapport parlementaire mais qui
est intéressant à souligner dans cette
loi même si
euh je rappelle que aujourd'hui du moins
il y a quelques années en 2011 dernier
chiffr dont j'ai disposé 70 % des peines
d'emprisonnement prononcé était àorti du
surcis 70 % par conséquent ça n'est pas
un effet
négligeable au total surci total 60 un
peu moins 59 % et surci partiel un peu
plus de 11
% l'absence d'automaticité de révocation
d'ci me paraîtêtre un assouplissement
non négligeable de notre politique
pénale je reviens d'un mot sur la
contrainte pénale pour en quelques
éléments
factuels je ne comprends pas bien le
partage des rôles entre juridiction et
jab dans cette affaire on dit la
juridiction peut accorder des mesures de
contrainte provisoire en attendant que
le décide des mesures de contrainte
définitive je me mets à la place de la
personne intéressée ça va très bien si
les mesures s'inscrivent dans une
parfaite continuité si elles sont
contradictoires d'un juge à l'autre ce
qui n'est pas à exclure je plains la
personne d'être soumis à quelques
semaines d'intervalle à des objurgations
si je puux dire de sens contraire ou en
tout cas de sens un peu différent
qu'est-ce qu'on dirait si un juge donne
une injonction de soin à titre
provisoire et si le il renonce par
la suite ou l'inverse bon moi je suis
plutôt à la condition naturellement que
les choses se décide très vite pour
confier au seul sur la base de
l'étude de la personnalité qui sera fait
par le PIP la définition des mesures
obligatoires peu importe euh je suis
aussi un petit peu perplexe sur le
manque d'imagination du législateur à
tirer les obligations qui peuvent naîre
de la contrainte pénale de la simple
énumération de celle qui existe déjà sur
s'agissant du surcis avec mise à
l'épreuve on transporte purement et
simplement les obligations moi je me
demande si euh il y a pas une
disposition plus large à prendre je sais
bien bien que le code de procédure
pénale et d'interprétation stricte mais
rien n'interdit me semble-t-il d'ouvrir
au juges la faculté de prendre toute
disposition qui lui paraîtra adapté à la
fin qu'il poursuit et à la personnalité
de la personne qui se trouve devant
lui je suis
aussi la question est de savoir
si le plafond qui qui qui existe pour un
éventuel emprisonnement pour qu'il
n'excède pas la dur de la peine encourue
n'est pas absolument évident mais je
n'estime pas sur ce point et je voudrais
en terminer là sur la contrainte pénale
il y a un autre point simplement que je
voudrais sur lequel je voudrais assister
votre attention appeler votre attention
parce que il me paraît important dans
les autres disposition figure un de de
de dispositions qui élargissent les
pouvoirs de police des services de
police et de gendarmerie pour
aller retrouver des personnes qui ne
remplissent pas leurs obligations
et à ce titre on crée une retenue une de
plus qui peut-être Lim qui doit être
limité à 24 he mais qui permet à la
police de mettre sous clé pour
l'interroger sur ce point la personne
qui ne remplit pas ses obligations bon
on prend soin de préciser dieu merci que
on lui donne un sbre de droit à cette
personne tiré notamment des articles 63
2 à 633 je crois du code de procédure
pénale je regrette mais il y a des
protections de ce code de procédure
pénale qui figurent au 635 et 636 qui ne
sont pas applicables et je ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne sais pas pourquoi
notamment le
635 indique qu'on ne peut pas pratiquer
la fouille intégrale n'importe comment
je ne vois pas pourquoi ça ne
s'appliquerait pas euh à la personne
ainsi retenue par conséquent je souhaite
que l'ensemble des garanties s réserve
évidemment de celles qui ne sont pas
applicable au cas d'espèce mais
l'ensemble des garanties valaes pour la
garde- à vue soit applicable trans posé
à la retenue voilà je je m'arrête là et
je voudrais terminer sur un dernier
point monsieur le Président si je ne
suis pas trop loin non ça va sur ce qui
ne figure pas dans le projet de
loi alors ce qui ne figure pas dans le
projet de loi pardon d'être un peu
d'être un peu désordonné ici ce sont
différentes dispositions qui me
paraissent intéressant la première c'est
que ce projet de loi parle d'abondance
de l'évaluation de la personnalité à
plusieurs reprises et on donne à ce
sujet au au service pénitentiire
d'insertion et tr un rôle éminent je
voudrais quand même que la loi précise
un tout petit peu plus même je ne crois
pas m'éloigner de l'objet de la loi hein
à laquel auquel je suis sensé je
voudrais que la loi précise un petit peu
plus ce que c'est que cette évaluation
de la
personnalité il y a des enjeux très
importants là-dessus je me permets de le
dire je rappelle que nous avons
introduit dans le code de procédure
pénale en 2005 l'idée de dangérosité qui
a fait fleuress depuis puisqu'elle a été
reprise un grand nombre de de cesconst
et d'occasion
législative je voudrais savoir qu'est-ce
qu'il faut entendre par évaluation de la
personnalité à quoi s'intéresseon
précisément la deuxième chose que je
voudrais évoquer c'est la rétention de
sûreté je ne vais pas m'étendre sur ce
point mais j'ai rendu un avis publ au
Journal officiel un avis du 6 février
qui figure au Journal Officiel du 25
février dans lequel j'ai
alerté les pouvoirs publics sur le
risque d'inconstitutionnalité qu'il y a
à pratiquer aujourd'hui la rétention de
sûreté qui est actuellement pratiquée
elle s'applique à des gens qui n'ont pas
respecté les obligations de la
surveillance de
sûreté ces personnes qui sont astreint
une surveillance de sûreté sont pour
aller vite de grands
criminels le fait de ne pas respecter
des obligations n'est pas un grand
crime par conséquent asreindre les
personnes de cette nature je renvoie ici
à la disposition de l'article 706 5319
du code de procéure pénale dernière
alinéa asreindre ces personnes à une
rétention de sûreté alors que au moment
où ils ont été condamnés pour leur crime
cette prétention de sûrté n'existait pas
et alors que la faute qui leurit
reproché n'est pas de nature criminelle
manquait une obligation d'un juge ça
n'est pas un
crime me pose problème et je reste
persuadé que la cour de si elle était
saisie sensurit ce dispositif sur la
base d'une jurisprudence qu'elle a déjà
eu notamment à propos des Basques
espagnoles en 2013 je n'iniste pas sur
ce point tout ça est public 3è
élément la détention elle-même alors
c'est là-dessus que je suis obligé de
dire que la loi me déçoit énormément je
ne cache pas les choses je crois que la
prison est victime par nature d'une
sorte de malédiction puisque personne au
fond ne sait ce qui s'y passe
et je maintiens que les conditions
carcérales font beaucoup pour la
prévention de la récidive ou
l'encouragement si je pu dire à la
récidive et en ce moment on est bien
entendu sur la deuxème
hypothèse je voudrais simplement pour
terminer parce que je veux pas allonger
mon propos évoquer trois domaines mais
je pourrais revenir sur les conditions
carcérales si vous
voulez trois domaines qui me paraissent
essentiel peut-être
d'aborder le premier c'est celui de du
travail en détention je rappelle que
actuellement le travail est très peu
encadré en détention sauf par les
dispositions de la loi pénitentiaire
mais dont je suis obligé d'avouer ici
devant vous que elle me paraissent
minimaliste je crois j'ai eu l'occasion
de vous le dire je sais bien sûr que le
Conseil constitionnel l'année dernière
au printemps a validé les dispositions
législative actuelle mais a donné toute
liberté au législateur sur ce point de
renforcer l'encadre
qui prévut aujourd'hui du travail en
prison je crois que c'est une occasion
qui nous est donné de le faire le
deuxième domaine c'est celui de
l'ancellumement individuelle nous sommes
devant une échéance qui prend fin en
novembre 2014 qui a été celle de la loi
pénitentiaire dont l'article 100 a prévu
un surcis à l'enellumement individuel
condition naturellement des de la
surpopulation j'ai publié sur ce point
un avis au Journal officiel du 23 avril
dans lequel je dit que on peut essayer
d'évoluer sur cette question et le
troisième domaine c'est l'aménagement
des peines et je suis un peu étonné que
si la loi est relativement prodigue dieu
merci sur l'aménagement de peine en
milieu ouvert ou plutôt sur les
possibilités d'aménagement de peine à
partir du milieu fermé je regrette
qu'elle ne soit pas davantage diserte
sur l'aménagement de peine de droit
commun euh c'est-à-dire celui qui est
accordé sous forme de réduction de peine
et cetera et cetera bon je pense en
particulier que il faudrait ouvrir
l'aménagement de peine à des critères
qui sont plus variés que celui ceux
d'aujourd'hui je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
par exemple le critère du travail est un
élément décisif pour l'aménagement de
peine je rappelle que la prison est
capable d'offrir aujourd'hui du travail
à à peine plus d'un/4 des détenus par
conséquent les tr/4s d'entre eux pour
aller vite se trouvent privé hips au
facto de tout aménagement de peine
possible ce qui est quand même paradoxal
et je voudrais qu'on introduisent par
exemple dans l'aménagement des peenes
les conditions de détenenstion dès lors
évidemment qu'elles ont un effet très
négatif sur la personnalité de
l'individu il s'agit pas d'abandonner la
personne je ne suis pas comme on le sait
favorable au numérus clausus mais je
pense qu'on peut rattraper
éventuellement ce qu'induit la
surpopulation dans les motifs qui
peuvent conduire à des Amon je voudrais
terminer sur un pour être concret parce
que c'est ça possiblei peut-être qu'on
attend de moi sur un exemple très très
précis pour vous montrer que les Ch
choses ne sont pas vraiment très simples
il s'agit d'un détenu qui a été placé en
en semiberté le 16 décembre
dernier il a de la chance parce que il a
250 € en poche ce détenu là c'est
beaucoup plus que la moyenne de ce qu'on
enochche les détenus qui
sortent il est à Nant affecté à Nant en
centre de
semiberté il est inscrit à une formation
de poseur monteur aménagement à
saintnazer
il s'est inscrit à Pôle emploi dès le
jour de sa sortie de prison le 16
décembre il n'y a pas de problème de
logement puisqu'il est en ce centre de
semiliberté donc à cet égard il a
beaucoup de
chance il va de Nant à saint-nazer en
train peut pas faire autrement il a
demandé une carte de réduction pour
travailleurs on va aller vite qu'on
appelle la carte acti le 23 décembre 6
jours après sa sortie pour payer des
billets avec 75 % de
réduction mais pour l'avoir lui a-t-on
dit il faut attendre minimum 15 jours
donc il pe le trajet à tarif plein
aller-retour 17,80 €
ensuite soit pour les 2 semaines
d'attente 177
€. il a dû acheter un téléphone avec une
espèce de Moby car parce qu'il pouvait
pas se payer un abonnement 9 € il lui a
fallu des photos d'identité pour sa
carte acti 5 € et puis surtout à midi il
faut qu'il se nourrisse quand même il a
donc déjeuné 6 fois pour 6 € 54
€ il a été au centre communal d'action
sociale pour avoir une aide et on lui a
refusé toute aide puisqu'il relevait de
l'administration pénitentiaire du centre
de semi liberté il a donc contacté son
conseiller pénit POCI d'inertion et de
probation son interlocrice dans un
premier temps lui a dit qu'elle allait
s'occuper de lui et notamment essayer de
lui trouver des tickets services et puis
dans un deuxième temps elle a fait des
efforts elle a rappelé pour dire que B
c'était la fin de l'année qu'elle avait
plus de budget et par conséquent plus de
ticket
service donc si je fais le compte de
tout ça au bout de quelques jours la
personne a plus rien en poche rien en
poche et naturellement il faut qu'elle
attende
la fin du mois au mieux voir la fin du
mois de janvier pour bénéficier de sa
rémunération de formation
professionnelle qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait il a eu la chance
de nous écrire on l'a renvoyé sur une
association caritative je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs s'il a été prise en charge on
a pas eu de ces nouvelles mais je
voudrais insister pour dire que cette
personne elle a bénéficié de chance que
non pas la plupart des sortant elle
était recasée elle avait plus d'argent
elle avait une formation et donc donc je
crois que la sortie et par conséquent
les conditions de cette sortie et par
conséquent les la prévention de la
récidive c'est pas encore réglé dans ce
pays merci monsieur le
Président bien merci Monsieur Jean-Marie
de la rue pour cet exposé qui je pense
nous aura
beaucoup appris touché intéressé
Jean-Pierre
Michel merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais être très très bref pour
laisser la place à à nos collègues poser
des questions je remercie Monsieur de la
rue
d'avoir abordé tout tous les problèmes
que pose ce texte en fait et de nous
donner donc un certain nombre de de
pistes de réflexion lorsque nous aurons
que ce texte retira de l'Assemblée dans
quel état pour l'instant je n'en sais
rien je voudrais dire un mot de la
contrainte
pénale personnellement je pense que la
contrainte pénale est une nouvelle peine
point sans point d'interrogation or
comme vous le dites la question se pose
et que donc
elle doit être prise comme ça ce n'est
pas l'antichambre de la
prison ça peut l'être dans une autre
condamnation mais ce n'est pas ça et et
et je suis je pense qu'il faut là-dessus
bien préciser le texte et d'autre part
je suis d'accord avec vous pour dire
vous avez fait la comparaison avec les
CEF pour dire que on peut faire la
comparaison le droit des mineurs aussi
ou le juge peut prendre toutes les
dispositions qui lui semblent
nécessaires qui lui semblent utiles par
rapport à à la personnalité hum mineur
par rapport à sa situation et cetera et
cetera pour l'exécution d'une peine en
milieu ouvert donc
là-dessus moi je partage très largement
votre point de vue sur le
reste évidemment si on vous écoute il
faut il faut toujours se souvenir ce que
vous avez dit tout à fait au début de
votre intervention voilà au début or
le texte il n pas exactement celui-là
voilà c'est-à-dire que
il il essaie de limiter la récidive il
s'appelle prévention de la récidive mais
il ne pose pas le principe que la récive
est d'autant plus importante que le
l'incarcération et comme si comme ça
voilà donc là-dessus aussi moi je suis
sensé par ce que vous avez dit et je
pense qu'on peut trouver un certain
nombre d'améliorations au texte
qui s'inscrit merci
donc Colomba oui qui s'inscrit Catherine
tas y a-t-il
d'autres bien j'ai 4 inscrit contenu des
questions matérielles je vous proposer
bien là sauf s'il y a des regrets dans
ce cas dites-le tout de suite il y a pas
de regret donc on va donner la parole
aux quatre intervenant successivement
pierreive
Colomba bien deux points d'abord je
voudrais vous remercier de la façon dont
vous avez pris le problème enfin ça nous
a pas
étonné
alors ma première question en fait c'est
c'est votre sentiment que je que je
sollicite vous avez
effectivement fait observer moi ça m'a
toujours frappé l'augmentation du taux
d'
d'incarcération on nteint pas les
sommets américain mais quand même c'est
quand même préoccupant alors que quand
on regarde l'évolution des
choses un peu
abstraitement nous on passe son temps à
créer des
droits passe son temps à créer des
droits et cetera puis on augmente les
droits plus on incarcère des gens c'est
un peu bizarre quand même
bon donc je je me pose un peu cette
question alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
jusque disons aux années vous dites il y
a une accélération ces 15 dernières
années je remarque quand même que ça
correspond à la campagne aux années
2000 2000 enfin et cetera où le thème de
la sécurité est devenu un thème
politique majeur le clivage politique
n'étant plus possible en matière
d'économ et de finances et bien ma fois
il fallait trouver autre chose ENF ça
c'est mon interprétation qui n'engage
que moi mais enfin ça me paraît quand
même pollué gravement gravement le débat
donc bon j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment si si vous ne voulez pas vous
me le direz pas mais c'est je trouve ça
assez assez curieux et qui est en
liaison avec une remarque que vous avez
faite c'est qu' on manque totalement en
France d'études sur essayant de de de
cerner la corrélation qui peut y avoir
entre certaines condition extérieure de
la société et cetera et puis euh et puis
la et puis la et puis la délinquance 2è
point je serait beaucoup plus plus bref
vous dites que vous vous appelez à à
préciser que la loi précise euh ce
qu'elle entend par évaluation de la
personnalité dout en
fort que l'on puisse évaluer la
personnalité notamment que l'on puisse
évaluer contrairement à ce qu'on dit la
dangerosité je me demande si comme on
peut pas faire autrement que de dire il
faut évaluer la
personnalité que rester dans
un certains vagues pourrait éviter
peut-être plus que créer donc des pour
éviter un certain nombre de de dérivve
un peu trop technicienne et techniciste
on avec jeanren le sererf on avait fait
un déplacement donc au au Canada on
avait quand même été un petit peu un
petit peu interloqué par certaines alors
c'est des grands amateurs in de ce on
était un petit peu interloqué quand même
de la façon dont ça se passait alors que
c'était des gens remarqua par par tout
autre s tout aspect voilà je par été
trop
long ah oui oui non mais il y avait des
choses ah
oui c'estucide Catherine TASC
merci monsieur le Président je veux vous
dire Monsieur le contrôleur général que
j'apprécie beaucoup la manière dont par
rapport à ce projet de loi vous resituez
le la prison l'emprisonnement au cœur
des des causes de la la
récidive et non pas simplement la
mauvaise nature des des délinquants et
et criminels je pense qu'il faudra
vraiment garder
ce cette approche là lorsque nous
débattrons de ce
texte parce que comme vous l'avez dit
l'emprisonnement a pris quand Mme même
une une part croissante et que et là
votre expérience nous nous éclaire
beaucoup les conditions de
l'emprisonnement demeurent très loin de
ce qu'on pourrait souhaiter donc c'est
une approche qui me
paraît très très importante je voulais
vous demander de préciser vous avez dit
lorsque vous avez évoqué les les peines
restrictive de liberté que le projet de
loi avait manqué d'imagination euh et
que il serait bien de d'imaginer
d'autres formules que la liberté
conditionnelle est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus
là-dessusè merci monsieur le Président
et merci Monsieur le contrôleuros vos
propos sont extrêmement passionnant et
tout le travail que vous faites est
vraiment pour nous une source de
réflexion je voudrais vous poser vous
demander
d'approfondir six points donc quatre
vous vous les avez évoqué mais
j'aimerais voir comment par rapport à ce
projet de de loi on pourrait s'en servir
vous parlez du du quantum des longues
peines qui n'est pas
toujours accepté est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il serait possible de de faire comme
dans certains pays qui limite la durée
maximum des peines et est-ce que ce
n'est pas justement la longueur de la
peine un un facteur de de de récidive et
surtout de de commission d'actes
répréhensible au sein des des maisons
enfin des des centres de détention
voir lorsqu'il y a une tentative de
d'évasion le rôle de la famille euh en
en prévention des longue peine qu'est-ce
qu'on pourrait faire pour que la la
famille devienne un partenaire euh
efficace on va dire de la euh de de la
lutte contre la prévention
euh vous parliz de de l'encellulement
individuel et je en tant que qu'ancienne
avocate et attend aller quand même
pendant mon mandat
dans une dizaine de de centres de
détention je demandais est-ce que c'est
vraiment la la panacée est-ce que plus
que l'enseignement en cellulement
individuel est-ce que d'avoir des des
petits régimes de de liberté de droit au
enfin de de droit au sein de la des
centres de détention avec ce qu'on a
actuellement comme les différenciations
des régimes régimes porte ouvertes porte
semi-ouvertes ou porte fermées est-ce
que c'est pas là aussi un des moyens de
redonner en quelque sorte une autonomie
au aux personnes condamnées pour que
elle ne soit pas totalement démunie
après lorsqu'elle deviennent elle
retrouent la liberté parce que je crois
qu'on a réellement surtout pour les
longues peines un problème d'incapacité
de vivre dans une vie libre après avoir
passé un longtemps en en prison euh je
me pose aussi le le problème du du
critère du travail comme vous monsieur
le contrôleur euh quand euh nous avons
de plus en plus de vieux détenus ne
serait-ce que parce que l'âge d'entrer
en en délinquence n'est pas toujours la
la prime jeunesse mais notamment pour
les les délits sexuels on les les les et
les crimes sexuels on les découvre
extrêmement tard et donc nous avons
énormément de de vieux détenus et je
pense certaines centes détenenstion
comme par exemple Melin où je crois que
la moyenne d'âge doit être de de 50 ou
60 ans c'est absolument incroyable et
est-ce que comment remplacer ce critère
du travail lorsqu'il n'y a plus de toute
façon de possibilité de travailler parce
qu'on est quasiment arrivé à l'âge de la
retraite dans le civil lorsque l'on sort
de prison et puis ma ma dernière
question alors peut-être que je ne l'ai
pas entendu mais quel est le rôle du du
du personnel pénitentiaire comment
former le personnel pénitentiaire
qui sont des gens extrêmement dévoués
avec une des conditions de travail
extrêmement difficiles moi je suis
toujours étonné quand quand je les
rencontre de leur de de leur cris de
leur appel à l'aide en disant aidez-nous
parce que finalement c'est ça que qu'on
entend lorsque l'on va visiter les
prisons aidez-nous non seulement pour
améliorer
le le cadre de le cadre d'emprisonnement
mais aussi aidez-nous pour nos nos
conditions de travail alors qu'est-ce
que le personnel pénitentiaire je dirais
pas de base mais qui n'est pas qui n'est
général pas celui qui est dans les SPIP
mais celui que l'on appelait avant les
matons
et en quoi est-ce comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait les former pour qu'ils aient un
autre rôle que simplement de contrôleur
de la vie en prison comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait les former pour qu'ils
deviennent aussi des acteurs de la la
prévention de la récidive merci
beaucoupci et enfin Jean-René leer oui
merci monsieur le Président quelques
quelques remarques sur lesquelles je
souhaiterais avoir effectivement les les
réactions de Monsieur le contrôleur
général la première c'est de dire c'est
très bien de faire des lois mais on
n'est pas capable d'appliquer les lois
que nous avons précédemment voté donc ça
pose déjà un petit problème la loi
pénitentière je constate par exemple que
nous avions souhaité qu'il y ait une
étude de de de de l'importance de la
récidive par établissement pour peine ça
n'est toujours pas effectivement ça ne
s'est toujours pas concrétisé par le
biais d'un décret d'application or
c'était effectivement pour nous la façon
de connaître l'incidence des conditions
de détention sur la récidive donc il y a
il y a quand même quelques années que la
loi a été votée l'obligation d'activité
l'obligation d'activité qui a pour le
législateur était un élément important
là aussi de lutte contre la récidive et
qui n'était pas qu'un travail qui pouvit
être une formation qui pouvait être
l'apprentissage de de de du français de
la lecture de l'écriture elle s'applique
de manière tout à fait homéopathique et
sans aucune volonté politique puisque il
y a de temps à autre des des initiatives
qui sont prises par la pénitentiaire qui
sont intéressantes je pense j'ai souvent
citer l'exemple d'un centre de
d'initiation de formation auut sélective
de déchets qu'on aurait pu dupliquer
qu'on a jamais cherché à dupliquer donc
première remarque effectivement à quoi
bon voter une loi nouvelle quand on
n'est pas capable d'appliquer les lois
précédemment votées euh d'autre part il
me semble qu'il y a un problème qui a un
problème considérable qui qui demeure et
qui a entrave très largement les
réformes c'est le problème de l'opacité
du milieu carcéral en général et de
l'administration par pénitentiaire en
particulier je crois que aussi longtemps
qu'on considéra pas les les les prisons
de la République comme les palais de la
République c'est-à-dire des des lieux
qui appartiennent aux citoyens ou donc
peuvent rentrer ce dont c'est la
profession d'informer notamment les
journalistes euh on n'avancera pas
beaucoup parce que euh on laissera se
développer des idées totalement erroné
sur la réalité du milieu carcéral et on
sait combien il est facile de manipuler
l'opinion sur sur sur sur ce genre de
problème euh je euh même chose les
aménagements de peine hier la contrainte
pénale euh aujourd'hui euh je je je suis
convaincu que ça sera considéré dans peu
de temps comme étant des cadeaux qui
sont réalisés effectivement aux
personnes détenues alors que ce n'est
pas du tout le cas et que si on les
considère comme des cadeaux c'est
effectivement un échec immédiat et je
pense qu'on a s'interroger effectivement
sur nos responsabilités collectives euh
à la fois enfin moi je suis assez assez
stupéfait quand quand j'entends
effectivement une sorte de procès en
sorcellerie à à à un projet de loi qui
est le projet de loi tobira qui à mon
avis na vraiment strictement rien de
révolutionnaire et en revanche je suis
également un peu pétrifié lorsque je
constate que au bout de 2 ans d'une
alternance il n'y a pas eu quoi que ce
soit d'évolution en matière législa on
change pas les lois par par circulaire
et que on se retrouve donc avec une
situation en matière de surpopulation
carcérale qui n'a pas d'équivalent pour
ainsi dire par rapport à notre histoire
donc c'est c'est c'est un constat qui a
un constat un petit peu calabiteux sur
lequel j'aimerais que vous nous rendiez
un peu
d'espérance bien merci merci à tous
alors Monsieur le contrôleur général oui
monsieur le Président je vais essayer
d'être bref malgré la richesse de des
questions et je je suis pas sûr de
pouvoir y répondre entièrement par
conséquent à toutes monsieur le sénateur
Colomba sur le thème de la de la
sécurité euh bon il y a beaucoup de
d'éléments à dire je rappelle que la
sécurité après tout est entrée dans la
loi comme un droit fondamental en 1995
ça n'est pas si vieux que ça et et on en
fait aujourd'hui le le premier droit
souvent dans la préstentation qui en est
fait des citoyens bon on peut toujours
gloser là-dessus moi je crois
personnellement que si la surpopulation
obéit à une pluralité de
facteurs le thème sécuritaire en est
certainement un mais il y en a d'autres
je crois par exemple que il est
incontestable alors c'est peut-être lié
à ce qui précède me direz-vous que les
juges ont prononcé ont eu tendance à
prononcer des peines de plus en plus
longues ont multiplié les peines courtes
par conséquent la surpulation elle s'est
accrue par les debouts si je puis
dire sur l'évaluation de la personnalité
si je souhaite en parler c'est
précisément parce que cette marchandise
peut recouvrer deux choses bien
différentes une étude qui tendrait à
montrer la nature criminelle d'une
personne et c'est ce que font en effet
les anglo-saxons et puis un pays
européen qui n'est pas l'Angleterre en
plus euh sur ce qu'on appelle les études
à à viser actuariel c'est-à-dire
déterminer à partir des question simple
il y en a d'ailleurs une vingtaine euh
est-ce que vos parents ont divorcé tôt
est-ce que vous avez commencé à fumer à
quel âge et cetera de ça on déduit que
la personne va pouvoir récidiver et
commettre un nouveau crime abominable de
plus bon euh je crois que ça c'est une
première hypothèse et la deuxième
hypothèse c'est de chercher moins
inventorier la la la perspective
d'avenir que les données effectivement
présentent sur comment se conduit la
personne de façon objective queles sont
quel est son environnement familial quel
est son environnement social est-ce
qu'elle a un métier et cetera et cetera
ça me paraît ça deux choses totalement
opposées et je milite clairement pour la
deuxième hypothèse parce que la première
me paraît très clairement aventureuse
c'est pour ça quand la loi parle
d'évaluation de la personnalité
j'aimerais bien qu'elle nous dise un
petit peu ce qu'elle entend parler euh
sur la question de madame taska je
voudrais dire simplement que euh il y a
aujourd'hui de façon très précise la
liberté conditionnelle le PSE la
semiliberté et le travail d'intérêt
général bon moi je crois que de façon
générale toute perspective d'aménagement
de peine aujourd'hui c'est au fond des
contraintes qu'on impose à quelqu'un de
faire quelque chose et à cet égard on
lui impose régulièrement des contrôles
moi j'ai souvenir de quelqu'un qui
m'avait écrit parce qu'il était en
désespoir menace de réintégrer la la
prison il avait pas rempli une
obligation parce qu'il avait une urgence
médicale bon et et son conseiller
pénitentiaire d'insertion deation ne
voulait rien entendre sur le fait qu'il
ne se soit pas présenté à l'UR dite
devant le juge et cetera et cetera bon
je crois que les gens sont placés devant
des contraintes impossibles pour eux à
remplir je prends l'exemple aussi d'une
des dispositions de l'article 132 45 qui
numère les obligations don peut-être
aujourd'hui à sorti le scil avec mise à
la preuve on dit obligation de résidence
fixe bon quand on sait les démêlés qu'on
peut avoir pour trouver un logement
quand on sort de prison cette
disposition me paraît totalement
surréel donc moi je crois que il
faudrait passer sans que le terme
évidemment est une connotation juridique
mais il y aurait une formule qui mirait
assez bien qui con évidemment avec des
gens qui sont en état de le faire à
passer avec eux une sorte de contrat de
de finalité autrement dit voilà vous
disposez chers monsieurs à compter
d'aujourd'hui et vous pouvez pour ça
requérir l'aide de d'association qu'on
va vous désigner et cetera de d'avoir à
trouver un logement et un emploi dans
les 6 mois qui viennent B et à ce
momentlà on verra ce que vous êtes
capable de faire et à la fin on l'évalue
pour lui dire quels efforts avez-vous
fait vous monsieur personnellement pour
vous en sortir cette espèce de de de
Paris fait sur une personne me paraît
plus intéressante qu'un alignement de
contraintte bureaucratique qui sont
souvent un voilà la perspective dans
lequel je voudrais qu'on aille c'est pas
du tout je reconnais l'esprit actuel euh
pour Madame Lipietz je voudrais dire
s'agissant très brièvement et je vais
pas avoir le temps de me justifier mais
je sais que je vais choquer un som
d'entre vous oui c'est vrai je ne suis
pas sûr que euh des peines qui soient
aujourd'hui de l'ordre de 25 30 ans ou
perpétuel sont adapté même à DESC
criminels je crois qu'il y a eu des
paroles très très sensées qui ont été
dites depuis longtemps sur ce point et
moi je souscris àez volontiers même
s'ils ont une tradition pénale
différente de la nôtre à ces pays qui
limit à 10 ans maximum on sait très bien
à quel dilemme a été confronté la
Norvège quand il s'est fallu quand il
lui a fallu sanctionner monsieur Brevic
qui était l'auteur quand même de
quelques assassinats assez nombreux et à
qui on a dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
puisque on peut pas le condamner à plus
de 10 ans bon et ben nous peut-être il
faut faire une réflexion en sens inverse
voilà sur le rôle de la famille moi je
souhaiterais tout simplement globalement
que la
pénitencire estime de ce devoir de son
devoir de travailler pour quelque
détention que ce soit même en maison
d'arrêt mais à forcierie en
établissement pour peine avec la famille
autrement dit faire venir son épouse la
mère le père pour d'abord demander des
informations sur la personne qu'on vient
d'incarcérer et voir avec lui avec elle
la meilleure manière de de de prendre en
charge cette personne je crois qu'il y a
un travail conjoint qui m'intéresse
puisque j'ai dit tout à l'heure que la
famille est le principal élément
d'insertion de réinsertion à la sortie
il faut donc que ça commence dès
l'entrée en prison bon sur ce point il y
a beaucoup de choses à faire mais je
vais pas avoir le temps de les
développer sur l'enseignement individuel
moi je crois que si c'est un élément
très important de la préservation du
droit au respect de la vie privée de la
personne du respect pardon du droit à la
vie privée et par conséquent je crois
que l'enseignementiv est une obligation
sauf naturellement pour ceux qui
estiment pouvoir vivre à plusieurs en
cellules on peut pas imposer l'inverse
je rappelle que cette assemblée a
défendu mordicus ce point de vue en 2009
au moment de la loi pénitentière par
conséquent je crois que c'est un élément
majeur de des conditions d'incarcération
ça n'exclut pas naturellement une
différenciation des régimes pénitentiaes
je mets en garde simplement contre une
différenciation qui consiste à se dire
que régime fermé régime ouvert
aujourd'hui le régime porte fermé en
prison devient un succès d'anné de la
sanction disciplinaire qui ne dit pas
son nom c'est-à-dire qu'on envoie en
porte fermée des gens qu'on ne veut pas
punir avec les procédures habituelles
mais en réalité c'est bien ce sens-là
que ça et par conséquent on a des
déviations un petit peu fâcheux
sur le le personnel euh moi je suis pas
sûr que la formation soit à revoir la
formation est plutôt bonne ce qui est à
revoir c'est la manière dont les gens
exercent leur fonction évidemment très
difficile évidemment très difficile mais
cette reconnaissance et de la difficulté
et cet hommage que nous devons au
personnel ne doit pas cacher que la
plupart d'entre eux se comportent comme
s'ils étaient la loi en prison et je
crois je l'ai dit au président de la
République un jour dis y a une
révolution dans ce pays qui consisterait
à dire que les fonctionnaires respectent
les lois bon et notamment les
fonctionnaires des services de sécurité
je n'insiste pas sur ce point et enfin à
Monsieur le CF je je je lui donne acte
de ces de ces remarques en effet la loi
n'est pas respectée ça nous empêche pas
évidemment de concevoir de nouvelles
lois mais ça nous appelle à vérifier en
effet de façon très précise nous sommes
j'espère complémentaires sur ce point
l'effectivité des lois il y a beaucoup à
faire encore dans ce pays sur ce point
et sur l'opacité de de l'administration
pénitentiaire je crois qu'il y a un
projet de loi qui comporte une
disposition mais il a été repoussé qui
permet l'entrée de journalistes qui
accompagnent des parlementaires toute la
question je me suis permis de le dire à
les journalistes toute la question de
savoir comment l'administration
pénitentiaire va concevoir ses visites
de journalistes voilà
merci bien entendu cher collègu je ne
vais pas vous présenter Robert Badinter
puisque à ces nombreux titres et ces
nombreuses qualités que tout le monde
connaît il est chez lui ici
puisque on sont son esprit plane
toujours sur les débats de la salle 216
là-haut et des autres salles où nous
nous réunissons alors aujourd'hui nous
avons non seulement l'esprit qui plane
mais l'être dans
son
intégrité donc je salue Robert Badinter
je le remercie d'avoir bien voulu
accepter de venir nous parler je vais
lui donner la parole tout de suite pour
une intervention liminaire sur ce projet
de loi et puis peut-être après nous
aurons si vous voulez bien un débat
alors Monsieur le monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègu chers
amis alors chers Président chers amis ça
marche encore oui je n pas besoin de
dire le plaisir que j'éprouve à me
retrouver ici je vois tant de visages
amicaux et sur des questions que peut le
dire très franchement non pas le mérite
d'une originalité brûlante il y a
longtemps que nous entendons parler de
ces problèmes il y a longtemps que nous
revenons sur ces questions et on a le
sentiment que euh cette fois-ci
peut-être en tout cas pour une partie la
sagesse va prévaloir il faut donc
compter évidemment sur l'intervention du
Sénat nous n'avons pas le texte qui est
encore à l'état de travail à l'Assemblée
donc qu'est-ce qu'il en adviendra nous
verrons mais en ce qui concerne la
participation au rôle du Sénat il est
évident que comme le plus souvent c'est
pour le meilleur alors mieux vaut le
préparer tout a été dit
j'écoutais ces armes ce que nous ont dit
je l'aurais moi-même exprimé avec autant
de passion que Madame tulkin c'est
autant de précision que madame maestai
vous connaissez parfaitement ces
questions qu'est-ce quel est
l'apport du texte que l'on nous
propose je vous dirais très directement
et avec la plus entière plus entière
conviction le texte va dans la bonne
direction il ne va pas assez loin c'est
un bon texte inachevé et c'est pour ça
que le Sénat a un rôle particulier à
jouer alors pourquoi est un bon texte
parce que il revient à des principes qui
nous sont tout à fait chers qui ont été
perdus de vue dans la décennie
précédente et surtout dans les dernières
années précédentes
2012 et
particulièrement s'agissant de la
question majeure de la place de
l'emprisonnement par rapport aux autres
pénalités mais aussi la question liée à
cette place de l'emprisonnement qui est
celle de l'individualisation des peines
individu
peines et des sanctions est un principe
fondamental auquel on n'est pas assez
attaché et je rappelle sur ce point ce
qui a été énoncé par le Conseil de
l'Europe mais comme toujours nous sommes
en retard dès l'année 2000 on était déjà
là à montrer quelles étaient les voies
dans lesquelles nous devions nous
engager mais nous nous y engageons bien
mais tardivement et à mon sens
insuffisamment alors il faut quand même
rappeler ce ce qui est l'échec constant
constant de la politique pénale que nous
prations en France et qui est le taux
d'incarcération pour moi c'est l'indice
on le regarde nous avons connaissons
tous les conséquences détestables de
l'incarcération spécialement en matière
de courte peine et nous savons que en
regardant le taux
d'inincarcération au mesure ce que je
dirais être euh
l'indice plus ou moins satisfaisant ou
si l'on préfère plus ou moins détestable
de résultat de la politique pénale la
politique économique retrouve sa
sanction toujours dans le taux de
chômage pour moi s'agissant de la
justice pénale le taux d'incarcération
traduit en chiffre très nettement ce
qu'est le succès ou l'échec des
politiques pénales non pas que on puisse
atteindre le mythe qu'amait évoqué fouco
dans des temps déjà très lointain
c'est-à-dire d'une société sans prison
j'avais eu l'occasion de lui dire
envoyez-moi cher Michel foucot le projet
de l'avant projet de loi je serais très
heureux de le présenter pour voir la
réaction il a rit il aimait beaucoup
rire je ne l'ai jamais reçu mais telle
qu'elle est telle qu'elle est telle
qu'elle existe la prison et spécialement
les conditions qui sont les nôtres il
est évident que la mesure la mesure de
l'échec pénal pour moi se s'inscrit dans
ce taux d'incarcération alors je le
rappelle quand même et et sans
satisfaction il y avait au 1er janvier
48594 détenus 1er janvier 2002 il y
avait 10 ans plus tard
67073 le taux avait augmenté de 38 %
dans cette période 38 % vous mesurez ce
que cela veut dire par rapport à 2002 et
il est resté il n'a pas diminué il est
resté
constant nous avons atteint le chiffre
de
68859 par rapport au 67000 que
j'évoquais il y a un instant en
2012 donc nous avons une
augmentation par rapport à 2012 d'encore
2,66 %. l'accélération l'augmentation a
singulièrement
diminué
mais la continuité demeur dans ce
domaine pas faute il faut le dire de
texte que nous avons voté ou qui ont été
voté par la majorité de l'époque mais
c'est ACI alors la situation est encore
encore plus perplexe si on veut bien
considérer que heureusement
heureusement le taux de recours le
nombre de recours au brcelet
électronique a permis je dirais de de
contenir cette inflation nous avons
aujourd'hui au 1er avril 2014
11234 personnes qui sont sous brassel
électronique donc je nose dire sur on
les ajoutait mais en considérant ce que
c'était au 1er janvier 2002 s'il n'y
avait pas le bracelet économie
électronique et le recours au bracelet
où en serion-nous où en serions-nous
avec ce que l'on sait être la situation
pénitentiaire actuelle surtout surtout
au niveau des maisons d'arrêt alors
l'individualisation des peines doit
évidemment
permettre de diminuer ce recours le
projet offre à cet
égard des peines substitutives et des
peines alternatives je ne discuterai pas
de la portée des
adjectif je dis simplement que je crois
pour ma part
que les propositions faites par la
conférence de consensus méthode que
j'approuve entièrement don on a pas dans
le projet tiré
exactement toutes les conséquences loin
de là j'ai un tableau que je vous
remettrai monsieur le Président dans
lequel j'ai très exactement confrontter
les dispositions des 12 recommandations
de la conférence de consensus avec les
propositions du projet de loi à bien des
égards nous en sommes loin ou sinon loin
en tout cas écarté donc ça c'est la
première observation je tiens à faire à
quoi bon réunir autant de personnes
compétentes émanant de tous les horizons
de la vie judiciaire et également la
doctrine si c'est en définitive pour
n'en pas tirer toute les conséquences là
c'est très agréable grande messe
académique et les juristes qui sont
habitués mais ça n'est pas seulement
pour orner les rayons des bibliothèques
mieux vaut les faire entrer dans les
textes euxmêm sous réserve de quelques
considération je rappelle d'ailleurs
c'est un peu perdu de vue pardonnerez
c'est retour en arrière et cette in
Curion dans
l'histoire de la législation le grand
succès
de notre histoire législative c'est
indiscutablement la période
napoléonienne et plus particulièrement
celle du consulat et je me suis beaucoup
interrogé sur le point de savoir
pourquoi un militaire même de génie
avait réussi là où ses prédécesseurs
avaient échoué et notamment en ce qui
concerne le Code civil qui a quand même
été réalisé dans les conditions à la
fois extraordinairement rapide mais pour
une jourée constante puisque comme le
disait si bien le Loyen carbonniier la
France change toujours de constitution
politique mais elle conserve sa
constitution civile toujours on a changé
énormément de choses mais c'est toujours
le Code civil alors j'ai regardé de très
près la méthode suivie et le coup de
génie de Bonaparte
politiquement a été de se dire je j'ai
aucune légitimité il éétait pas là par
le privilège de la naissance et il
n'était pas non plus élu par le peuple
publicicite bon donc où est la
légitimité la légitimité je vais le
trouver dans quoi dans l'ordre juridique
en fondant un ordre juridique qui
ralliera tous les Français j'aurais
acquis le socle de légitimité qui me
fait défaut puissance puissante
intuition peut-être inspiré par certains
de ses grands conseillers je crois pas
que ce fut C peut-être portalist mais en
tout cas l'idée a été à partir de
l'avant projet de faire circuler et
débattre sur celui-ci avec un rapport de
synthèse final au Conseil d'État dans
toutes les assemblées de toutes les
cours d'appel et notamment et surtout à
la Cour de cassation et le travail de
synthèse
qui tiré est finalement le dernier
moment de l'élaboration mais le à moins
le sens presque aussi important que laav
projet du Code civil et pourquoi estta
si important à part souci politique que
j'ai évoqué c'est parce qu'il
savait il savait que si il
associait la
totalité du corps juridique et
judiciaire à l'élaboration du Code civil
ce serait leur uvre et quiétant leur
uvre ayant oublié l'origine mais il se
chargeit de
lesiller il veillerait à ce que ceci
soit respecté il les avait associés par
la même coup de génie politique il on
été à ce momentl très porteur pendant
l'époque du Conat coup de génie
politique qui a permis d'assurer sans
difficulté la mise en œuvre du code et
de la conserver comme étant l'expression
d'un consensus juridique total et bien
là à partir de la conférence de
consensus je pense que on aurait dû en
tirer les
conséquences d'abord parce que je les
trouve pour l'essentiel je le
dis de très loin ce que l'on a produit
de mieux depuis très longtemps dans ce
domaine et deuxièmement parce que on en
avait débattu et que le rent était
général et que c'est très important pour
la suite des textes voilà première
observation je
souhaiterais je
souhaiterais bien cher ami que vous
regardiez de très près la différence
vous la connaissez je vous laisserai le
tableau qui a été fait il y a encore
beaucoup à faire donc ça c'est en ce qui
concerne la méthode alors ce qui
d'ailleurs ça a été repris très bien par
euh le comité consultatif euh des droits
de l'homme euh moi je vous le dis
clairement ça a été évoqué tout à
l'heure par Madame tulkin le moment est
venu de savoir ce que vous voulez faire
ou c'est la Xe réforme en attendant la
suivante et puis attendra à son tour la
prochaine ou cette fois-ci on dit stop
j'évoquais le mot de consensus et tous
ensemble on examine ce qui peut être
fait pour les décennies à venir et en
particulier et sur la base de ce que
sont les propositions et je dirais le
consensus européen je rappelle toujours
que notre droit ne peut être que
projeter dans l'avenir européen s'il
veut perdurer ne serait-ce qu' à cause
du contrôle exercé par les juridictions
internationales européennes si vous le
regardez c'est vrai que la proposition
des trois piliers des trois piliers la
prison elle existe mais elle peut être
système de référence pour l'ensemble des
pénalités donc la
prison
laapobation les anglosaxons dirai ATL
mais l'approbation recouvrant l'ensemble
des mesures qui ne sont pas des mesures
d'emprisonnement et dans lesquelles il y
a dans le cadre général de l'approbation
différentes sections correspondant à
tout ce que sont les mesures
alternatives mais rassembler de façon à
ce qu'on prononce la peine depration et
à l'intérieur de la peine depration
ensuite on prend les catégories utiles
au regard de l'individualation des
peines et enfin ce que sont les peines
pécunières et cetera avec le jourment
mais vous voyez du coup tout devient
plus clair sinon enfin clair la prison
l'approbation c'est-à-dire des mesure de
contrainte pénale s'exerçant sur un
individu selon sa personnalité et les
fait et en troisième lieu les sanctions
pénales et notamment dans le domaine
économique et financier et notamment
s'agissant des personnes morales où on
trouve naturellement leur place alors
c'est ça que on on on trouve euh aément
à partir de la conférence de consensus
et je le souhaite
profondément sur ce point que vous
adoptiez cette structure de trois
piliers très clair que à ce moment-là
dans le cadre de
l'approbation vous examineiez et tratiez
de la contrainte pénale en soi pers
comme étant une dé fores majeure sur
lesquel nous comptons oui mais si on en
fait une des formes de substitut à
l'emprisonnement non seulement vous
minorez sa portée symbolique mais vous
ne faites rien d'autre que une autre
forme de surcis avec mise à l'épreuve et
ce qui devait être une grande réforme à
partir de la conférence de consensus
devient quoi devient une réforme de plus
dans lequel on bricole quelque chose de
compliqué inséré dans l'ensemble mais
qui n'est qu'une des forme de surcil
avec mise à l'épreuve le décrochage de
l'emprisonnement est ici une
nécessité il faut dépasser le le stade
immédiat de la technique et reprendre en
sa total porter ce que l'on veut faire
on parle de réforme si on fait une
réforme il faut une véritable réforme
alors ne parlons pas de réforme disons
ajustement
modalité amélioration mais surtout
n'utilisons pas le TER
apporter à la procédure
française judiciire pénale une nouvelle
forme de surcil mise à
l'épreuve difficile de annoncer une
grande réforme he franchement donc là il
faut saisir l'occasion et effectuer
cette l'élaboration de ce système en
trois piliers ou de ce triptique si vous
préférez la peinture alors voilà l' tion
première que je sur ce qu'est
aujourd'hui la contrainte pénale sur la
contrainte pénale je dirais bon
oui il un petit problème de
constitutionnalité qui se pose moins je
pense vous n'entendz rien vous n'z pas
le droit de manifester quel opinion que
ce soit mais c'est pas inexact la j'ai
retrouvé même qui avait mis le doigt
là-dessus il y a la question de la
sanction de l'ineexécution des
dispositions de la contrainte
pénale sur ce point il faut y prêter
attention juge de l'application des
peines saisissant un autre juge qui va
prononcer une peine d'emprisonnement à
quel titre pour une exécution de mais
c'est pas une infraction c'est une
exécution d'une décision antérieure
c'est pas la Constitution en infraction
sauf à être prévu au moment du prononcer
alors on voit où le le risque s'annonce
et je crois je crois que on résout le
problème à partir du moment où on dit il
y a une probation peine de probation
sanction l'ineexécution de la peine de
probation cela constitue une infraction
en soi et à partir de là les choses se
déroulent simplement euh celui qui
méconnaît euh la mesure de probation qui
pèse sur lui si la mesure de contrainte
pénale se trouve commettre une
infraction et dès lors tout redevient
possible constitutionnellement sans
incertitude en ce qui concerne alors les
autres mesures mais je si vous voulez me
poser d'autres questions sur la
contrainte pénale je vous répondrai bien
volontiers et je je je tiens je tiens à
dire que il n'est je n'ose pas le mettre
à l'imparfait il n'est que temps
puisqu'elle existe encore d'en finir
avec la peine
planché au moment où la peine planchée a
fait son apparition je me souviens
encore de propos éloquents qui ont été
tenus par un certain
nombre sénateurs
présents tout le mal possible n'a été
dit il est contraire l'individuation de
la peine il n'a pour effet que de
renforcer encore la surpopulation pénale
au niveau des maisons d'arrêt et puis
c'est
c'est pense profondément pas
seulementage pas seulement
méconnaissance de l'individualation il y
a là une forme de carcan imposé à la
liberté des magistrats qui en soi ne
correspond à rien de ce que'est la
pénalisation moderne ça c'est ce retour
à des à des peines minimales
automatiques c'est insupportable et donc
je le dis aussi ça aurait dû disparaître
dès le début de la
législature là je par cont je ne
comprends pas pourquoi on a attendu si
longtemps avec une mesure si décriée et
Don on a vu les effets qui sont
détestables donc on aurait dû le faire
disparaître c'était en soi à faire
immédiatement bon c'est ainsi je je
connais je connais les les difficultés
que
rencontre tout garde des saau dans
l'exercice de ces fonctions et
particulièrement quand il s'agit
d'initiative qui le rallie pas le même
consensus qu'à la conférence mais il
faut le dire clairement là c'est c'est
c'est déjà tard alors au moins notons
avec satisfaction que ça sera fait je
tiens à dire que en aucune manière
aucune manière là je suis de la dernière
insistance vous ne sauriez accepter la
disposition du
projet qui prévoit qu'on redescend à 1
an ce qui est aujourd'hui le niveau
d'aménagement des peines qui a été fait
si j'ai bonne mémoire en 2007 beaucoup à
l'initiative des membres des commissions
des lois de et notamment disons-le à
l'initiative du président de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale la situation carcérale était
telle qui fallait procéder à remett
vigoureux cette mesure qui soutenu
devant nous Madame
Dati saluer cet instant de
grâce me référant j'ai pas voulu me
référer aux Actes des Apôtres mais enfin
il y avait eu un instant où l'esprit
avait soufflé redescendre un an est
totalement inadmissible ça n'a aucun
sens et la portée elle se traduit
directement voir la l'étude d'impact
fort bien faite par quelques milliers
d'emprisonnements en plus c'est que tout
le bénéfice qu'on pourrait qu'on pourra
tirer de la suppression des peines
planchées va se volatiliser et même plus
dès l'instant
dès l'instant on retournerait au plafond
de 1 an c'est donc
c'est à faire disparaître cette
disposition du pro il s'agit il y aura
un vote de consensus j'imagine parce que
personne ne peut conoir la raison pour
lesquelle on ferait cela et
particulièrement je dois dire un
gouvernement de gauche une majorité de
gauche mais cela vaut plus général
puisqueencore une fois cela est venu en
2007 je tire mais vraiment là ce n'est
pas concevable alors sur les libérations
conditionnelles tout le monde est
d'accord nous sommes tous d'accord ça il
faut éviter les sortie sèche et que
l'invitation à considérer la situation
au 2 tiers est une invitation sage dire
qu'elle est de droit comme certains y
aspirent son réserve d' c'est-à-dire
inversé
opposition moi je pense que ce qui doit
être inscrit dans la loi c'est
l'obligation de se pencher sur le sort
et de voir assez de tiers au plus tard
parce que on peut le faire avant quelle
la situation Sant libération profelle
c'est une question de
politique judiciaire conduite par les
magistrats il est certain absolument
certain que dans ce domainelà
l'expérience prouve que la sortie sèche
est la plure de table et que s'agissant
notamment des
récidivistes et ou de ceux qui ont
commis des infractions grave parfois
très grave encore à forceerie
doit-on veiller à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
une sortie sèche mais que ce soit le
processus de libération conditionnelle
qui s'exerce voilà les les les grandes
lignes de ce que je souhaitais dire au
départ encore une fois c'est un bon
projet encore une fois il n'est pas
achevé il n'est pas abouti et c'est
précisément le rôle du Parlement que de
faire en sorte que les bons motifs
s'inscrivent dans d'excellents
dispositifs voilà je suis à votre
disposition mes chers je n'ose dire
collègue on utilisera la
for comm merci Robert Badinter pour cet
exposé très fort euh je donne la parole
à chanierre Michel pour l'instant
monsieur le Président je n pas de
question à poser parce que je partage ce
qui a été dit donc je vais laisser mes
collègues poser des questions peut-être
qu'après si vousz peut-être je voulais
poser une question à propos
de la peine de probation ou contrainte
pénale une difficulté existe qui est la
suivante c'est que lorsque l'on pose la
question de quoi s'agit-il
exactement
concrètement ce n'est pas une
alternative à la détention ce n'est pas
la détention
c'est contrainte pénale peine de
probation
et je crois qu'il y aurait grand intérêt
à rendre concrète cela parce que on
puisse dire à la télévision voilà ce que
c'est parce que si on ne réussit pas à
bien expliquer cela il y a une
difficulté pour ce texte pardonnez-moi
de dire ça je sais pas pourquoi je qui
je me donne cela de faire donner de me
prendre la parole alors qui veut la
parole tout le monde monsieur Anziani
Colomba le
SER monsieur yest monsieur yest il
a-t-il d'autres demandes on en a que
quatre bon alors on va commencer avec
quatre Monsieur le Doyen he alors
Monsieur Anziani
oui monsieur mon Président une
intervention très brève d'abord pour
dire que moi je partage pleinement les
propos qui viennent d'être tenus par
Monsieur
balinter et que c'est vrai que le but
n'est pas de faire une réforme pénale
pour en faire une supplémentaire mais
que le but est de faire une réforme
pénale qui donne du sens à la peine et
qui donc prévient la récidive et je suis
pas sûr que le texte aujourd'hui permet
d'atteindre ces ses objectifs ma
question elle est plus précise revient à
celle de posée par le président de la
commission des lois j'ai quelques
inquiétudes quand même sur la contrainte
pénale euh parce que j'imagine mal ce
que les praticiens et donc notamment les
juges vont en faire ou quand je dis
j'imagine mal je crain imaginer ce que
ce qu'ils vont faire c'est-à-dire pas du
tout ce que le législateur
veut je crois qu'ils ne savent même pas
aujourd'hui comment s'y prendre avec la
contrainte pénale donc il faudrait qu'on
arrive à lui donner un sens beaucoup
plus précis quelque chose de beaucoup
plus concret sinon je pense que c'est
vraiment un risque de dévoiement
important d'une partie importante de la
réforme merci Dian pierre
Colomba vu la façon dont la réforme
s'est engagée j'ai des espoirs très très
réduit quant à ce qui va en sortir mais
puisque Robert nous fait le plaisir
d'être à nouveau parmi nous j'en profite
pour aborder un point moi qui me paraît
qui me paraît essentiel par-dà ce
problème de la réforme tout à l'heure
bon il a rappelé l'envolet de l'usage de
de l'incarcération mais ça ne date pas
de des années 2000 où effectivement il y
a eu euh une un usage disons politique
ou pour pas dire politicien euh de euh
de le du thème de la délinquence tout à
l'heure donc Jean-Marie de laarue était
là et précisément nous a indiqué ça je
dire que si si j'ai bien relevé les
chiffres qui nous a donné entre 75 et et
1995 on est passé de 28000 un
carcération à 53000 donc c'est pas euh
bon il y a il y a une montéeon donc ce
qui moi ma question c'est la suivante
pourquoi et ce qui pose une autre un
autre un autre problème que Alan Ziani a
abordé tout à l'heure c'est le problème
du du sens de la du sens de la peine
comme disait fouco il n'y a rien de plus
difficile que punir fouo ayant abandonné
très rapidement ses utopies et entre
surveiller et punir et puisquil a publié
après il y a eu quand même quelques
évolutions donc moi ce qui me frappe
dans la façon dont on aborde ce problème
de la justice et tout à l'heure on n'
pas eu de débat donc on pas pu
intervenir mais
euh la la philosophie enfin au moins
comme je ressens de la de la la
conférence du consensus bah notre fois
c'est une philosophie allez on
béavioriste on remplace la moralisation
par le
formatage mais qu'est-ce que c'est le
sens de la peine qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire dans une société comme la nôtre que
de redonner sens à la peine et de faire
autre chose de la peine que bah une
mesure de régulation sociale mettre à
l'écart un certain nombre de gens et
cetera et je crois que tant qu'on euh
tant qu'on se posera pas cette cette
cette question qu'on arrivera pas à y
trouver vraiment début de de de de
réponse et bien on sera réduit à à
essayer de faire des réformes qui se
heurent toujours à un mur
d'incompréhension mur d'incompréhension
donc avec lequel il est souvent facile
de jouer pour ben ma fois avoir des
résultats sur le plan
politicien merci Monsieur Colomba
monsieur leer merci monsieur le
Président trois courtes questions là la
la première rejoint justement ce
problème du sens de la peine le sens de
la peine qu'on avait eu effectivement
beaucoup de difficultés à insérer dans
la loi pénitentiare avec pas mal de
controverses mais je pense qu'on avait
bien fait effectivement d'inséret en
prévoyant effectivement que dans dans
dans dans les raisons de la peine il y
avait aussi la réinsertion et la
possibilité de mener une vie exemple
d'infraction ce ce ce cette définition
du sens de la peine va revenir dans dans
dans la réforme amélioré
vraisemblablement mais encore
faudrait-il qu'on en tire les
conclusions c'est-à-dire que lorsqu'on
visite les prisons et qu'on voit
effectivement qu'il à peu près 10 % de
personnes pour Don don dont la la l'état
l'état mental est tel que la peine n'a
aucun sens ça n'a pas changé quoi que ce
soit que nous ayons effectivement prévu
le sens de la peine au niveau de la loi
pénitentiaire deuxième point est-ce
qu'il faut pas insister sur les moyens
c'estd toute politique pénale est une
politique qui demande des moyens alors
si on peut comprendre spontanément que
construire des prisons ça coûte cher et
qu'il faut embaucher des personnels de
surveillance mais une politique qui
s'éloigne effectivement de de de de
l'emprisonnement systématique vers des
aménagements de paix des alternatives à
l'incarcération exige aussi des moyens
et des moyens quasi aussi importants moi
je me souviens toujours de de de euh la
la l'étude d'impact qui était lidié à la
loi pénitentiaire qui prévoyait que
cette loi ne pouvait être opérationnelle
que si on recrutait au moins 1000 agents
d'insertion et de probation lesquels
n'ont jamais été recrutés donc là aussi
il y a une contrainte qui qui s'impose à
nous et puis je revenais je reviens sur
ce que ce que vous disiez sur le
problème de l'aménagement de peine
l'aménagement de peine que nous avions
effectivement dans la loi pénitentiaire
prévue effectivement pour être
la la solution quasi systématique
jusqu'à 2 années soit de abinitio soit
soit de années effectivement récentes
que l'on peut faire repasser à un an
dont on nous dit parfois on avait
d'ailleurs eu beaucoup de mal avec le
président yest à faire en sorte que la
loie pénitentiaire ne soit pas modifié
largement sur ce point mais on nous dit
parfois c'est pas très grave qu'on
ramène à un an à partir du moment où il
y a désormais l'approbation possible
jusqu'au 5 ans donc il y aura de toute
façon de la part du juge la possibilité
dans des hypothèses qui étaient
couvertes auparavant par ces de années
d'avoir un substitut à la
prison merci Monsieur le monsieur yest
oui monsieur le Président on est
d'ailleurs je moi je suis très honoré
que le président Badinter vienent nous
voir sur ce sur ces sujets
euh moi j'ai toujours une question mais
qui n'est pas que personne ne peut
résoudre est-ce que la prison augmente
la récidive ou le fait qu'il y ait pas
de pris ils ont continué la récid ça
dépend du type de délit on connaît tous
des
multirécidivistes réitérant parce qu'ils
sont pas encore récidivis parce Queen
plus les notions sont assez floues euh
je citerai toujours le cas de ce jeune
de 16 ans qui avait en espace de 3 mois
commis euh 57 dél graves c'est-à-dire il
piquait des bagnoles il piquait des
bagnoles hein et puis il décassait
d'ailleurs céta époque pour les vendre
euh et jusqu'au jour où les policiers
disent pour qu'il est 16 ans celui-là
parce qu'on va on on va on va l'arrêter
on va arrêter malgré toutes les les
mesures
mais nous monsieur le
Président l'esprit de la loi
pénitencière c'était si quelqu'un est
incarcéré et condamné je parle pas des
prévenus parce que il y a quand même on
pourrait dire beaucoup de choses aussi
pourquoi il y a tant de de de de de de
personnes en Dét tenstion est-ce que le
nombre de prévenus augmente parce que la
justice a de plus en plus de choses à
faire avec des moyens limités donc ça
dure plus
longtemps tout ça c'est c'est il
faudrait quand même préciser les choses
parce que moi je veux bien que on fasse
des lois théoriques mais il faut voir
les réalités or nous avions dit et je
crois que c'était l'esprit de la loi
pénitentiaire et c'était quand même un
progrès c'est de dire toute personne
doit
commencer on doit commencer à préparer
sa sortie au premier jour où il est
incarcéré ça veut dire et et on a eu ce
matin Jean-Marie de la rue donc c'est
c'est un bon observateur nous disait euh
le travail c'est un problème
euh enfin tout est un problème et et
donc l'individualisation de la peine ça
veut dire aussi comment on soutient les
personnes je parle pas du de ce qu'a dit
Jean-René le cerf qui est un défaut à
mon avis de notre système et c'est pour
ça qu'il y a eu la rétention de surûté
malgré tout c'est que des des des
condamnés à des longues peines qui est
quand même qui ont quand même des
troubles
psychologiques sont en France en prison
alors dans d'autres pays européens n'y
le sont pas
oui parce qu'on oublie de dire ça on n
pas résolu ce problème quand même
donc moi je me je m'interroge quand même
euh la contrainte pénale moi je sais
toujours pas en plus exactement ce que
c'est hein je partage un petit peu le
l'interrogation par rapport à à un surc
mise à l'épreuve ou je ne sais quoi et
ça sera peut-être interprété comme ça
par les magistrats faudrait quand même
donner du contenu à cette contrainte
autrement on aura fait une réforme pour
pas grandchose à mon avis mais le
problème le plus important et on l'a dit
c'est
que on ne peut pas faire de
réforme sans graves conséquences et
retournement de l'opinion contre des
bonnes réformes si on y met pas les
moyens
alors bah c'est comme ça et depuis
toujours et quand on compare les autres
pays européens parce qu'il faut on fait
quand on fait les comparation
internationale on s'aperçoit que il y a
quand même des différences de moyens qui
qui font que on peut avoir des
politiques mais si on dit on va faire
une politique et puis en fin de compte
s'il y a pas assez de de conseiller
d'insertion et de probation et cetera
puisque c'est c'est c'est pour ça que la
loi péniten ne fonctionne pas en partie
pourquoi quand vous faites la la
semiliberté quand vous faites des
libérations conditionnelles si vous
n'avez pas préparé et si vous n'avez pas
des gens qui accompagnent si on laisse
les gens dans la nature et ben
évidemment il se produit des
catastrophes même si elles sont pas
nombreuses mais ça a un tel impact sur
l'opinion publique que ensuite c'est
dénoncé et et et et et et l'opinion
publique s'inquiète ce sont des réalités
monsieur le Président que vous
connaissez bien mais que nous
connaissons hélas depuis trop longtemps
aussi merci
Jean-Jacques est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
questions qui serait venu dans le
fil non il n'y a pas de regret monsieur
zooketo vous n'avez pas de
regret monsieur Géard non plus monsieur
Delbard non plus m taska pas de
regret bien oui moi Président je je
confirme que on ne peut pas rester dans
le dans le flou sur ce que l'on met
derrière les termes
de de cette sanction alternative qui est
vécu comme alternative si on n'est pas
capable d'illustrer très
concrètement
ça la contrainte n'existera pas elle
elle sera absorbée dans l'échelle des
des mesure possible mais ça ne changera
pas le système si j'ai bien compris
quand même l'intention du texte c'est
que la contrainte
pénale soit une vraie invention nouvelle
par rapport à à la panoplie dont on
dispose aujourd'hui donc je crois que là
on touche un point absolument central du
projet merci madame taskaa je crois que
je vais redonner la parole à Jean-Pierre
Michel puis on va bien entendu donner la
parole à Robert Badinter mais il y a
vraiment un problème là si vous voulez
pour ce débat là tout le monde voit bien
qu'il y a une difficulté de
communication parce que il est très
facile de s'opposer à des dispositions
de ce genre avec des exemples
extrêmement concrets voilà ce qui s'est
passé regardez cette émission moi
j'étais là avec où il y avit Christiane
tobira on s'est retrouvé avec la mère de
la fille qui a
été agressée sauvagement et cetera et on
peut dire tout ce qu'on veut de
rationnel par rapport à 7 minutes de
télé comme ça c'est impossible à
quiconque de bon et par rapport à cela
on voit bien que le système actuel ne
marche pas il y a plein de de de peines
qui sont prononcé non exécuté compris
100000 peines d'emprisonnement qui sont
prononcé aujourd'hui et ne sont pas
exécuté donc l'idée est de proposer
quelque chose de plus diversifié et de
plus efficace mais il faut faut que l'on
puisse le l'expliquer le faire percevoir
je crois qu'on est plusieurs à être
sensible à cette question hein mais à
laquelle il y a peut-être pas de réponse
qui tombera du ciel Jean-Pierre
Michel je vois bien la difficulté mais
quand même ce matin autour après les
trois
audition moi je vois les choses assez
clairement il y a une peine privative de
liberté bon c'est la peine de prison
alors la difficulté c'est que cette
prison elle peut être
écourtée par un certain nombre de
mesures qui s'effectuent en dehors de
l'établissement pénitentiaire
ensuite il y a une plaine restrictive de
droit c'est la contrainte
l'approbation toutes les mesures sont
possibles je ne pense pas qu'il faut les
préciser dans la loi il faut dire que le
juge doit prendre toutes les
dispositions
par rapport à la personnalité par
rapport au à la gravité de l'infraction
et par rapport à l'environnement social
de la personne ça peut aller de la
suppression du passeport ça peut aller à
des travaux au travail d'intérêt général
ça peut aller l'assignation à résidence
ça peut aller et cetera et cetera ça
restraint les
droits dans la loi il faut dire que si
le condamné n'exécute pas ses
obligations il commet un
délit
parailt voilà et ensuite il y a une
peine pécuniare c'est l'amende
voilà alors merci pour tout cela je
pense que il est bien maintenant de
donner la parole à Robert Badinter pour
éclairer pour conclure aussi notre
matinée de travail alors monsieur le
Président chers collègue
oui oui cher président mais j'ai j'ai
écouté bien sûr avec intérêt et une
certaine nostalgie euh mais ça ne savout
pas une certaine ce qui était dit euh je
vais répondre à chacun et conclurai pour
finir très rapidement
euh le problème évoqué euh par vous mon
cher ch ami andiani s'agissant de la
contrainte pénale et de sa mise en œuvre
il faut en effet c'est très difficile
expliquer ce que ça sera pourquoi c'est
très difficile parce que pour
l'essentiel la contrainte pénale
existe sauf le mot la chose car si on
prend les multiples modalités du surcil
avec mise à
l'épreuve sauf à êt extraordinairement
inventif je sais bien que le droit la
plus puissante école de l'imagination
comme disait girudou enfin très
franchement aujourd'hui dans son état la
contrainte pénale c'est rien d'autre
qu'un sur avec la mise à l'épreuve
disons complété et dont on a changé en
gardant la bouteille et pour l'essentiel
le contenu
l'étiquette c'est pourquoi je disais
mieux vudrait en effet comm vous l'avez
évoqué aller clairement vers l'ensemble
des mesures la prison avec le surc surs
simplement
ensuite l'approbation dans lequel
s'inscrira à ce moment-là le surcis est
mise à l'épreuve qui n'existera plus au
niveau de la prison au moins on y
trouvera de la clarté en cours de route
qu'on améliore les choses ça arrivera
nécessairement dans les travaux de la
commission mais je je réponds à ça en
l'état ça sera très difficile à
expliquer
l'originalité de la réforme entre
guillemets
pénal moi on dira oui mais tous les
professionnels disent mais réforme
quelle réforme euh modalité changement
bon ça marche donc si on veut et on doit
je pense saisir l'opportunité qui nous
est offerte après la conférence de
consensus c'est en effet les trois
piliers et puis on dit voilà on a changé
en effet les possibilités vertu
l'umalité là ça devient clair et on peut
dire la réforme oui il y a eu une
réforme bon en ce qui concerne
euh la question euh posée par sens de la
peine vous
savez il faut je crois la distinguer le
sens et la
fonction la fonction de la peine on la
connaît tous depuis très longtemps et
elle est excellemment définie là aussi
par le triptique il en va rendroit comme
dans la Vals par le triptique la peine
c'est la rétribution je te troué le
terme bizarre la sanction pour dire les
choses
simplement c'est la dissuasion pour ceux
qui se disent et puis c'est ça c'est
l'esprit que nous devons conserver et
faire
souffler c'est aussi la réincertion et
je retrouve là ce qui avait certainement
été rappelé par la amie de la rue mais
Monsieur le CF et moi on souvent parlé
là où il n'y a pas réinsertion il y a
échec de la peine et par conséquent
c'est ds départ c'est dès le départ
comme le veut les recommandations du
Conseil de l'Europe qu'il faut pour des
parcours qui ne sont pas 6 mois de très
courte peine il faut aussitôt dès le
départ commencer le projet de
réinsertion ça c'est une orientation
capitale vous le Sénat apporterait ça à
ce projet cette exigence mais traduite
en mesure de réinsertion de préparer la
réinertion ça serait très important
alors en revanche si là c'est la
fonction de la peine le sens de la
peine
c'estz quand j'avais écrit la bien
longtemps la préface du oui la préface
du projet de nouveau code pénal j'avais
rappelé que il y a toujours toujours
toujours dans une
disposition qui est une disposition de
droit
pénal d'une
part une pénalité comme le texte indque
et d'autre part fonction répressive et
puis une autre un sens qui est
celui de la valeur exprimée je disais il
y a la fonction expressive et la
fonction répressive et la
fonction expressive c'est quelle valeur
se traduisent dans le code fait
aujourd'hui autre chose c'est
essentiellement un texte de procédure
pénale alors qu'il est une valeur ça
j'en suis convaincu expressive oui mais
sa première fonction c'est de clarifier
d'améliorer le système de mise en œuvre
de la loi pénale qu'au niveau de la loi
pénale ensuite on s'interroge sur
l'utilité ou la signification de telle
ou telle disposition ça va soit quand
quand on a tellement œuvré sur le crime
contre l'humanité nous savions quel
était le sens profond des disposition
qui nous permettait de déroger au
principe de la prescription on le savait
que d'autres ont voulu trouver pour
d'autres terrains mais là c'était clair
c'est ça que j'appelle véritablement le
sens donc ici c'est de la technique
j'ajoute simplement une remarque qui
certainement venu à l'esprit de beaucoup
moi ce qui m'a frappé pour l'avenir
c'est que cette loi restera quand elle
sera achevée comme
une sorte de consécration plus que
d'indication de du pouvoir
croissant des magistrats de
l'application des peines par rapport au
juges car si vous regardez de très près
dans le
détail les pouvoirs du juge de
l'application des pees ici ils sont
croissants par rapport à celui qui juge
en de temps temps peu
importe coupable non coupable quelle
peine le quelle
peine prononcé dans son cadre est
ensuite dans la main du juge de
l'application les P et là vous assistez
à ce transfert qui n'est pas nouveau
mais qui ici se vraiment très prant très
prignant y a il y a une transfert de
pouvoir du
magistrat qui juge de la culpabilité
prononce la peine à la mise en œuvre de
cette peine à sa modification à son
changement à sa transformation à sa
réalité quotidienne qui est considéra ça
restera dans l'histoire de l'évolution
de la sanction pénale alors en ce qui
concerne euh ce qu'a
évoqué le président yest
euh je trouve là avec les questions je
dirais si importantes de toute loi
procédure pénale la préparation de la
sortie je l'ai évoqué je sais que c'est
une nécessité alors ça pose plus
généralement une question question qui
ici sera au cœur des interrogations les
moyens les moyens c'est toujours la même
choses les moyens alors il y a une étude
d'impact j'ai vu elle m'est apparu
iste par rapport à ce qui apparaîtra
bien vite comme exigence le nombre de
juges prévus le nombre de greffiers
prévus et surtout du côté des SPIP ça me
paraît une enveloppe qui ne suffira pas
donc là il faudra que le Sénat
s'interroge c'est une question qui n'est
pas préjudicielle mais qui conditionne
certainement la suite de ce qui aviendra
de ce texte parce que combien on en a vu
qui ont échoué faute de moyens
alors que dire
d'autres ceci qui répond à ce que vous
avez
évoqué la question de la
compréhension d'un texte de procédure
pénale de droit pénal quand il n'est pas
le
renforcement aisé
et le mon on dressé de la fermeté tous
azimut qui est si commode comme
posture la question des victimes
qu'est-ce qu'apporte le texte aux
victimes vous aurez cette question bien
entendu a fait référence mais on vous
dira mais en dehors d'une mesure que moi
j'ai trouvé
singulière vous y réfléchirit est-ce
qu'il faut
véritablement faire connaître à la
victime
le jour ou le moment où
expire la peine qui a été
prononcé je me suis
interrogé vissance euh quelquefois c'est
des très nombreuses années après
réémergence de la souffrance sur croix
de risque que j'évoque mais qui est plus
théorique à mon sens mais qui peut
arriver du ceux qui n'ont pas fait leur
deuil qui cherche vengeance quelle est
vraiment l'utilité de cette disposition
d'information je ne sais pas je je
redoute plus ces effets que je nen voie
le bénéfice moral pour la victime alors
vous y réfléchirez pour le reste pour le
reste cher
Président j'ai
vécu 8 ans de ma vie en confrontation
télévisée à chaque fois qu'il était
question de l'abolliition de la peine de
mort avec les parents de la victime et
l'effet évident émouvant est
irrésistible il n'y a rien de plus
douloureux mais de plus douloureux et on
le conçoit que le
visage de la victime
ici la victime c'est son fils sa fille
son mari sa femme l'être
proche à ce moment-là tout ce que vous
pouvez dire en ce qui concerne les
fonctions évoquées la
réinsertion c'est à cet instant par
rapport à une victime
communément insupportable et vous êtes
vous-même parce que vous le ressentez
parce que c'est chez nous une forme
d'humanité je dirais pas
élémentaire que de sentir cette douleur
et et de la partager ça n'empêche pas de
poursuivre son action là le sens d'une
meilleure justice mais ce déséquilibre
il est structurel à l'image d'ailleurs
j'ai pour ma part une
conviction c'est
que
le le développement récent et toujours
intense du sentiment de V prant la place
de l'exigence de
justice le constant recours pour faire
passer des textes toujours plus
répressif aux victimes dont on doit par
ce moyen soulager la
douleur tout cela n'est pas bon n'est
pas bon il faut une solidarité sans
faille avec les
victime et il faut la plus grande
humanité possible dans l'approche de la
justice
au traitement je dirais concret effectif
des victimes com j'en l'ai vu qui
attendaiit des heures dans le couloir
d'instruction en dépit de toutes les
belles proclamations
mais
considérer la justice
pénale comme un lieu de catarcis pour la
souffrance ou le deuil de la victime
ou considérer ce qui pire encore que la
justice et pénale est une des formes que
état mais à la disposition des victimes
pour exercer ce que chacun comprend
c'està dire une soif de vengeance à
certains moment c'est pas la peine de se
lurer c'est l'être humain qui est ainsi
ça ça me paraît une grande erreur des
dernières décennies on envoie les
raisons humaines mais les conséquences
on les mesure aussi et à cet égard le
droit français dans les dernières années
dernières décennies pour réparer ce qui
était une froideur pas une indifférence
juridique il avait des droits mais une
froideur de l'institution n'a cessé
d'aller toujours plus loin et on peut
s'interroger à cet égard sur l'avenir de
la justice pénale ainsi je n'ose pas le
dire mais je le
pense mise au service de la vengeance et
d'une certaine manière le retour au un
lointain passé voilà ce que je pouvais
vous dire encore une fois is et je
conclurrai là-dessus tellement ça me
préoccupe ne cédez pas s'agissant du
la retour à 1 an en matière
d'aménagement des peines ceci n'est pas
consable VO ça je tenz à le dire en
finissant parce que c'est dans le projet
et que ça ne peut pas être maintenu bien
excuse-moi je suis là Jean-Pierre
Michel j'aurais aimé que s' le peut
moi je suis très choqué par la la
confusion qui existe entre le prenons le
le correctionnel parl pas de la Cour
d'Assise entre le juge correctionnel et
le
quelle est la légitimité du
est-ce qu'on ne doit pas arriver à un
système où le juge correctionnel se
prononcera uniquement sur la
culpabilité uniquement et où ensuite le
se prononcera sur la peine parce
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une très grande
confusion le juge correctionnel quand il
prononce un surc mise à l'épreuve il il
prenonce leses
mesures simplement le code le code de
procédure pénale dit que ensuite il est
sous l'autorité du ja je sais pas quoi
pour contrôler que ces mesures sont
effectives uniquement pour
contrôler dans le cadre de la contrainte
qui va prononcer à mon avis c'est le
tribunal tribunal qui va dire ce que
c'est que cette peine qu'est-ce qu'il y
met dedans et le JA doit être là
uniquement pour contrôler l'exécution
l'application voilà je pense qu'il faut
être très clair là-dessus mais bon
ultime
question sans oui oui c'est vrai mais
c'est bien sans retarder je dirais aussi
que moi je suis très sensible à ce que
dit Robert badinterre et il n'est pas le
seul dire sur les moyens simplement vu
la journée d'hier
notamment c'est vrai que si on veut
augmenter les moyens de la justice c'est
pas impossible mais il faut un courage
très grand par rapport à d'autres à
d'autres
chapitres ou mais les sous tombent Pasin
bon non mais ça bon écoutez pour rester
dans le cadre je n'ose dire de
l'enveloppe il y a quand même des
chiffres qui devraient rassurer à cette
cet égard rien n'est plus cher que le
coût de l'emprisonnement quand même le
rappeler je n'ai pas besoin aussi de
souligner le retard dans les
l'aménagement l'état des
prisons mais si vous regardez la
différence de coût entre le bracelet
électronique et la journée de détention
vous avez immédiatement une différence
saisissante
au profit de quoi d'une mesure qui tombe
dans le cadre de l'approvation et vous
pouvez redécliner l'ensemble des mesures
c'est toujours moins cher que ce que
coûte la journée de détention quand on
dit ah il nous faut d'abord construire
les prisons ensuite on mais c'est un
raisonnement économique complètement
erroné il n'y a rien de plus coûteux que
l'accroissement et l'allongement de la
détenenstion je ne dis pas pour autant
que c'est à cette h qu'on doit peser le
code pénal mais quand on évoque
l'argument financier je dis
l'enveloppe le succès et l'humanité tout
commande que on aille vers plus de
probation moins d'incarcération mais de
grâce simplifier les choses voilà vous
avez donc pu suivre l'audition de
Jean-Marie de la rue de Robert baninter
dans le cadre de l'examen du projet de
loi de forme pénale l'examen de ce
projet de loi est prévu au Parlement au
mois de juin tout de suite la suite de
nos programmes sur Public
Sénat